so you know when you're kicking someone
in the balls they wear a strap a leather
strap that they put in one shoe and it
goes up all the way down through there
growing all the way down to the other
and there's a leather strap there so
that you can really give them one you
know I never knew that
it's an old cowboy thing they developed
so that they could do the kick in the
balls and Newman did it for Butch
Cassidy Sundance Kid so they pulled the
strap out for the ball kick and I ended
up having to do it like almost 50 times
and my foot was swollen for a week from
kicking the ball and of course we had to
warm up you know I had to get the angle
right and I just kept kicking him in the
balls and like didn't we get this
because my foot is killing would you
throw we get it I would I like this one
where I go like like like watch out boys
don't fall in love she's gonna we're
definitely not gonna be what shape's
would you throw tom what shape were you
what were you given classic it's like
a little less gross
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
I'm sure you all saw the footage in in
it was on the papers and things online
of the accident yes and I think we all
kind of thought well how did you break
an ankle thing that does it look like
you should have broken your jaw or
something I know everyone said that was
the stunt I mean I'm gonna run across
and hit the side of the wall and then
pull myself over that wasn't the mistake
so you're always meant to not yes land
on the ruies okay
so what you know you brought us some
footage I think this is so cool to see
this from the different angle this is
what I I can't watch this most of it's
fine there's one clip but I will warn
you it's not for the screen
no see I'm wearing two wires they're
basically just safety wires because I'm
I go at a full tilt and I'm sprinting as
hard as I can and I hit the side of the
wall and that's the stunt I hit the side
of the wall and then I'm chasing after
Henry actually and all his fault I blame
you I can't decide the wall and then I
climb up on the wall and I'm supposed to
run Pascal okay so we've got this is the
shot from behind you so this is you see
the the speed and the momentum of the
run and it's in London there we go so
it's keeping me okay so here he goes but
you think how did you break a leg
so let's hook it up to the side just
list it from the side
this isn't about on the record so this
is from the side here we go we shot it
with three camera okay here he goes and
boom now now we've got a camera which
focuses on the foot now if you are
squeamish don't watch this show it to me
yeah
I mean a bone doesn't pop out or
anything but it is an odd angle for
anyone's foot to be out you never have
to do this yeah here we go here we go oh
my gosh so he jumps that speed that
momentum here we go
and watch that whatsit here here is why
here is why
Tom Cruise gets paid the big bucks okay
this is it from the front angle okay
so you've just seen what's happened to
his foot now watch this I knew I broke
it instantly to town now anyone else ago
well that's over no with the Blue Angels
and then I went when we were filming I
can my deal was when I made my deal I
said I've got to fly in the f-14 I made
it with the studio and I had to be
filmed in the f-14 live and so I had to
go through all the ejector seat training
and I couldn't wait to fly so in the
morning as their first pilot that I flew
with his name was bozo gives you
confidence yeah bozo bozo and we were up
there we had five minutes of film and we
had to turn you know we had to
coordinate he and I and we had other
airplanes coming in on us and there was
air combat maneuvers and we very
detailed briefings and everything so
we're going out and we're just right you
know I don't know a couple feet off the
deck in the desert and we're just
sweating I'm sweating in the f-14 and
because we were doing heavy maneuvers
and we did a really heavy maneuver we
pulled like nine and a half G's and I
you know you go out you've got a G suit
on but you know you just kind of black
out now when I came through it's like I
had my my barf bag right here my side of
the thing I was like okay so now I'm
gonna go get it done so I could do the
next take so I leaned down like this
pulled it I was like just went down like
this and he at that point decided to
pull up
pulled up so hard and for so long I mean
I can't do it now my head literally was
touching to the ground
g-force it explained and that pushes the
tops right here is going like this he's
like you know I mean he was going up
forever so finally he leveled off and I
just I had the bagman and I was like I
suppose him what didn't you see I like
you get a check you didn't tell me you
were gonna do that my head was like what
he says yeah yeah they don't call me
bozo for nothing no one properly told
you the timing yeah the guy was over
there and he said okay we're gonna go on
three and he started going three two one
I said whoa stop stop don't stop waiting
you know we have explosions gonna go
over my head and he said I said you just
said on three he said well I meant three
what what does that mean I said just
everyone's please he was like 2:00 in
the morning and they setting it up and
there's broking there's glass and just
tons of water and he said well I'm gonna
Cretu one and I said tonight do I go
then or do I go do I go on one like when
do I go do I go on one are you gonna
push the buttons it can explode on one
it was you know it kind of looked at me
like I don't know
when you hear the explosion just go
senior script something and you kind of
think I'm not going to do that actually
you know what that sounds too difficult
too scary or have you just thought
everything's just gonna go no let's do
it is that for me yeah oh no I I don't
know actually I really don't know I mean
it's not like all those stunts and the
things the sequences we kind of all
build them together what about the Last
Samurai with all those sticks like when
you get are just getting beat up that
was those guys were good they were
really would they not hit you you know
what he would just put it in enough I
mean those
you're like that hurts that hurts that
hurts
just keep talking tom keep talking so
tom tips for Jamie before it's so what
sort of a spatial expression should you
go for forever feels natural just yet
most important thing is don't get blown
up put your brave yes you know you can't
look terrified and I you're frightened
but you're still brave yes
frightened a brave what's the countdown
is it three two one go
okay so you're going on one on three
I'm doing okay okay so it's three two
[Applause]
let's let's see it lets see it Jamie
he's running he's running
[Applause]
[Music]
you